welcome to prison of elders prepare for
combat okay Tate last week we talked
about the trousers Osiris which is the
PvP portion of house of wolves let's
start PvE this week with the prison of
elders what is that all about yeah so
excited to talk about the prison of
elders it's the new endgame activity
it's kind of replacing the rain in a way
which is weird to say but it is the PvE
aspect of it and it's kind of like horde
mode with a twist I don't really want to
call it horde mode but it's like kind of
the easiest analogy I can make you drop
into a ship that has basically some of
the baddest wanted you know enemies in
the world that barracks is kind of like
locked up and he challenges you to beat
them for you know bounty and treasures
and all that there's four variations of
the prison of elders there's a 28
version a 32 version a 34 version and a
35 version now the 28 version is the
only one that's a matchmaker ball so you
can load up like you know your strikes
and whatnot and find two strangers and
do the 28 version and that consists of
four rounds however the 32 and 34 35
version you're going to need a fire team
and the reason that you're going to need
a team is because it's slightly it's
like kind of harder than you're just 28
version you know there's going to be a
lot of people that are higher level than
the 28 version so it won't be as hard so
unfortunately there's a slight barrier
but it's not as bad as trying to find
five people right so the cool thing
about the prisoner builders is there's
modifiers for each of these for air
locked rooms that you're going to have
to go into some are good some are bad
some of the bad ones are kind of like
the stuff you saw before you know
jugular a light switch so you have to be
careful depending on the round to make
sure you know hey it's jugular don't you
know make sure you're watching an
ammunition or there's good ones like
brawler it's like okay my mail a super
beefed up and I can like one shot a lot
of stuff because it's like three hundred
percent more damage or something like
that or catapult which recharges your
grenades faster so essentially you're
going into these rooms they're always
race specific so you're going to have
like a hive kind of room a fallen kind
of room of X kinda rooms
and each of those rooms you're going to
get three different waves of monsters
that are going to attack you depending
on of course the math that you have and
as you're doing that you might run into
something cool called a critical
objective now that comes in the form of
you know you have to not only kill the
monsters on a map but you also have to
like defuse mines in like three
different locations or you might have to
destroy some lines that are in three
different locations so you're going to
go from room to room to room until you
get to I think the fourth room which is
a boss and then your ultimate Lee going
to have to kill the boss that's in the
28th version but in the 32 and the 34
version there's actually a fifth room or
wolf it's not actually a fifth room but
you're going to go into a fifth room and
fight another boss and the cool thing
for me i did i did a 32 version and the
boss actually had a modifier that hasn't
been in destiny before and it's i guess
the easiest way to explain is like a
rainbow shield because he recalibrates
his armor dependent like it it's either
gonna go void or arc or solar so that
kind of forces you and your teammates to
kind of coordinate okay who's got a
solar weapon who's got a void weapon
who's got an art weapon and after you
kill him luckily enough at least in the
32 in the 34 version you're going to be
able to go into this really sweet
treasure room what happens is the the
doc in the middle opens up more or less
and you get to drop down kind of like
you would in vault of glass like through
the caves and inevitably you're going to
land into a kind of cylindrical room
that has a bunch of treasure
unfortunately can't show it to everyone
but it's like Scrooge McDuck's treasure
room you can kind of like see all the
gold and everything but there's a large
chest and two small chests at least in
the 32 version and the large chest has
you know an exotic new legendary weapon
which was like a Queen's wrath 11
interestingly enough a new class
legendary armor and then some like motes
and coins so the treasure room sounds a
little unusual for destiny a game that
usually doesn't give you a lot of
rewards for completing the weeklies you
know weekly strike or whatnot it's
always very random and it sounds like
from what you've described there was a
lot of treasure is that there to get
people to
x-lite level faster what's what's going
on there I think it's it's just trying
to reward the player for the time that
they spent right and taking away some of
the randomness is a really good thing
right it's something that even Diablo
did that which is why kind of had this
resurgence it's just that reward the
players were the time that they invest
right no longer are you going into the
night ball thinking like please please
please exotic exotic now it's probably
Please Please Please I etheric light but
with the treasure chest you know that at
least from what I could tell me and my
two teammates when we open it exotic
item we I think I got a weapon there was
a Queen's wrath a legendary new weapon
and then there was a legendary class
armor so and then also strange coins and
moats but it seems like at least you are
guaranteed an exotic and guaranteed a
new legendary of some sort and that's
very satisfying right as a player
knowing when you open this chest it's
not like a you know cross your fingers
hope that I get an exotic it's oh I'm
actually going to get exotic now it's
more like ah that wasn't an exotic I
want it but at least you know that you
got it right and that makes you feel
good right and I think that's kind of
what they're going for with the Treasury
all right so now the important thing
that we should talk about is you've seen
pretty much all of house of wolves
weekly content how do you feel in terms
of is this enough is there enough stuff
there to keep people and they'll you
know calm it happens I think just having
something new and different and is it
not like is refreshing enough that we
want to play it right like everyone in
the office is very interested right the
first time through my prison of elders
it was just like oh my god like crap
like we got to go over here we got to go
over there and there's just a lot of
scrambling and the the tents part of
that is like we're some of the fun is
right because you don't know what's
going to happen right and that's kind of
what the raid gave you it's like I
remember doing the crow to bridge part
it was like I don't how are we supposed
to get over there you know like let's go
to the back room and it's not
necessarily to the depth of that in
terms of puzzle solving but there are
like smaller things like the critical
objectives and things that you have to
put bill and I think this is good for
like the wider audience right like I
think it's actually a pretty good time
to get come back because it's easier to
get to a higher light level there's more
things for you to do
you that you couldn't do before because
in the past is like you meet by people
or you're kind of screwed out of that
last light level you're not there's
those restrictions are kind of go on now
right the accessibility is the big thing
and the new activities is what's going
to make this kind of fun like hopefully
fun enough to last until comment but
definitely fun enough for like the first
month easy no problem
victory well